This is 99% invisible. I'm Roman Mars. When new movies come out, most of the praise goes to the director and the lead actors, but there are so many other people involved in a film, and a lot of them are designers. They're a costume designers and set designers, but also graphic designers working behind the scenes on all of the graphic objects that you might see in a film. And I do mean every single graphic object. Anything with lettering on it, anything with pattern on it, and anything with illustration on it, and most things made out of paper. This is Annie Atkins. My name is Annie Atkins, and I'm a graphic designer for the film industry.
这里是“99%隐形”。我是罗曼·马尔斯。当新电影上映时，大部分的赞誉都归于导演和主演，但参与一部电影的还有许多其他人，其中很大一部分都是设计师。他们是服装设计师和布景设计师，同时也是平面设计师，在幕后负责你在电影中可能看到的各种平面物件。我是说每一个平面物件。任何有文字的、有图案的、有插画的东西，以及大部分用纸做成的东西。这是安妮·阿金斯。我叫安妮·阿金斯，我是电影行业的平面设计师。
Over the course of her career, Atkins has designed all kinds of graphic props. Telegrams, vintage cigarette packaging, maps, love letters, books, poems, any kind of chocolate box or food packaging at all, labeling passports, fake CIA identification cards. And with all of these objects, Atkins needs to choose or design the lettering and make sure the paper is just right. All of these small design decisions
在其职业生涯中，阿金斯设计过各种各样的平面道具。电报、复古香烟包装、地图、情书、书籍、诗歌、各种巧克力盒或食品包装、护照标签、伪造的中央情报局身份证件。对于所有这些物件，阿金斯都需要选择或设计字体，并确保纸张恰到好处。所有这些微小的设计决定
that contribute to creating a cohesive, visual world for the film. As graphic designs film, we really have two main priorities when we start designing any proper set piece. The first is to set the period, and the second is to set the location. So that when the audience start watching the movie, they know immediately where the story has been told and when it's taking place.
都有助于为电影打造一个连贯的视觉世界。作为电影的平面设计师，当我们开始设计任何道具场景时，其实有两个主要优先级。第一个是确立时代，第二个是确立地点。这样当观众开始看电影时，他们能立即知道故事讲述的是哪里以及发生在哪一个时期。
But I think the other thing that we have to do is we have to also try to tell the story at hand as well with graphics. So for example, if you see a sign in the background of a New York subway scene that says, walk, don't run, you can bet any seconds after you see that the characters are actually going to start running. All the graphic design you see in a film has a job to do. It's moving the story forward. Even if background signage seems to have a kind of a subliminal message,
但我认为我们还必须做的一件事是，也要尝试通过平面设计来讲述手头的故事。举个例子，如果你在纽约地铁场景的背景中看到一块标语写着“走，别跑”，你敢打赌，看到这个标语几秒钟后，角色们实际上就要开始跑了。你在电影中看到的每一项平面设计都有其使命。它在推动故事发展。即使背景标语似乎带有某种潜意识的信息，
it's always put their own purpose. Everything that we put in front of the camera is there for a reason. I met Annie Atkins at the AIGA National Design Conference, and I interviewed her on stage, and I just loved hearing her talk about her work. So I asked her to come on the show and talk more about it, and today we're just going to run part of that interview. So let's start at the beginning. How did you get into this business? My very first job was on a TV show called The Tudors, which we made here in Dublin and Ireland
它们也总是为了各自的目的而存在。我们放在镜头前的每一样东西都有其原因。我在AIGA国家设计大会上遇到了安妮·阿金斯，并在台上采访了她，我非常喜欢听她谈论自己的作品。所以我邀请她来到节目中多聊聊，今天我们只播放那次采访的一部分。那么，让我们从头开始。你是怎么进入这个行业的？我的第一份工作是在一部名为《都铎王朝》的电视剧中，大约十年前，我们在爱尔兰都柏林制作了这部剧。
about 10 years ago now. And I went for an interview for the job as an assistant to the art department. But when they saw my portfolio, they realized I came from a graphic design background. They said, well, we're actually looking for a full-time graphic designer on the show to create all the graphic pieces. And I couldn't understand this because it didn't make sense why they would need a graphic designer on a show that was set in a period before graphic designers existed. I'd come from this advertising background where we were making logo design websites magazine layouts and there were none of these things in the court of Henry VIII, right? But then I learnt very quickly when I started the job that just because there weren't any graphic designers in the 15th century, it doesn mean there wasn't graphic designers, just that at that time it would have been the craftspeople who were the designers.
当时我去面试艺术部门助理的工作。但当他们看到我的作品集时，他们意识到我出身于平面设计背景。他们说，嗯，我们其实正在寻找一名全职平面设计师来为该剧创作所有的平面作品。而我无法理解这一点，因为这说不通——为什么在一个平面设计师诞生之前的时代背景剧里，会需要一个平面设计师呢？我来自广告行业，我们当时在做标志设计、网站、杂志排版，而在亨利八世的宫廷里根本没有这些东西，对吧？但后来我开始这份工作后很快就了解到，仅仅因为15世纪没有平面设计师，并不意味着没有平面设计，只是在那个时候，是那些工匠扮演了设计师的角色。
So, for example, if Henry VIII wants to chop his wife's head off, he's going to need a death warrant. And if he needs a death warrant, he's going to need a calligrapher. Because at that time, it would have been the calligrapher who is responsible for the layout of the royal scrolls and documents and also the style of the lettering. So you become the graphic designer for the 15th century? Yeah, exactly. So now it's the graphic designer's role in film today to try to imitate what the crafts people would have done, whether that's the iron monger or the glazier or the stone mason. Talk us through the process like how do you begin?
所以，举个例子，如果亨利八世想砍掉他妻子的头，他需要一张死刑令。如果他需要死刑令，他就需要一位书法家。因为在当时，负责皇家卷轴和文件的排版以及字体风格的正是书法家。所以你成了15世纪的平面设计师？对，完全正确。所以现在电影中平面设计师的角色，就是去尝试模仿那些工匠们会做的事情，无论是铁匠、玻璃匠还是石匠。给我们讲讲这个过程，比如你是如何开始的？
How do you know what your job is going to be? What does it mean to be a graphic designer on for a certain film? Well first of all I never know what my next job is going to be so I can't really I can't really prepare myself and I can't really learn every skill that I'm going to need. Like I don't know if my next job is going to be set in Victorian London or if it's going to be on a spaceship 200 years in the future. So what happens is I get the call, I arrive on set, I set up my toolkit, I sit down with the script and I go through the script and I mark out anything that sounds like it might be a piece of graphic design. And while I'm making this list, which we call a script breakdown,
你怎么知道你的工作会是什么？为某部电影担任平面设计师意味着什么？嗯，首先我永远不知道我的下一份工作会是什么，所以我无法真正地提前准备，也无法真正学会我将需要的每一项技能。比如我不知道我的下一份工作背景是维多利亚时期的伦敦，还是200年后的宇宙飞船上。所以发生的情况是，我接到电话，到达片场，搭好我的工具箱，坐下来研读剧本，然后通读剧本，勾画出任何听起来可能是平面设计的东西。当我在制作这个我们称之为剧本拆解的清单时，
I'm also beginning to research the periods or the genre or the storyline that I'm designing for. I do that for about six to eight weeks prep and then shooting starts and during that time, time is always against me and I'm churning this stuff out. How often are you making stuff right before someone has to hold it on film? Well, we try to get everything made if it's a prop, then we try to get it made at least a week before it's shot on,
我也开始研究我所要设计的时代、流派或故事情节。我为此进行大约六到八周的筹备，然后拍摄就开始了，在这期间，时间总是对我不利，我得源源不断地赶制这些东西。你多久需要赶制出别人马上就要在电影里拿在手上的东西？嗯，如果我们做的是道具，我们尽量在它拍摄前至少一周制作完成，
because there's inevitably going to be some changes that need to be made. When I was working on the Granbury Pesto Hotel, I had to make a little notebook for Ray Finds' character, Gustav. Gustav is a very precise character. When Ray Finds came in for his costume fitting, he had his notebook and all the other props that he needed for his character. He just noticed that there were no lines in the notebook, given that he made him a notebook with blank pages.
因为不可避免地会有一些需要修改的地方。当我参与《布达佩斯大饭店》时，我不得不为拉尔夫·费因斯饰演的角色古斯塔夫制作一个小笔记本。古斯塔夫是一个非常一丝不苟的角色。当拉尔夫·费因斯来试装时，他带着他的笔记本以及他角色所需的所有其他道具。他只是注意到笔记本里没有横线，因为我给他做的是一本空白页的笔记本。
He questioned that because his character was so precise, he thought maybe it should have lines in it. So we took the prop back up to the studio, and we remade the notebook, and we sent it back down again with lines, and that was fine. But then after the film came out, and I started doing some magazine interviews about designing graphic props, I used this as an example because I thought it was quite interesting, and quite a good example of the level of detail that we actually go into. But of course, all the journalist heard was that I was saying that Ray finds this some kind of diva. So actually, I actually stopped using that
他对此提出了质疑，因为他的角色如此严谨，他觉得里面或许应该有横线。于是我们将道具拿回工作室，重新制作了笔记本，并带横线把它送了回去，这就没问题了。但后来电影上映后，我开始做一些关于设计平面道具的杂志采访，我用这个作为一个例子，因为我觉得这相当有趣，并且很好地展示了我们实际深入到的细节程度。但当然，所有记者听到的只是我说拉尔夫·费因斯是什么 Diva（大牌/难伺候的人）。所以实际上，我后来不再用这个
as an example because that's not what I was saying at all, you know, it's really it's his job to make sure that the props are right and this our job to make sure that the props are right and there's our job to make sure that the props are right And this is just the kind of back and forth the everyday back and forth that we go through when we're making things for a film set So when you're doing that script breakdown What are some of the key words that you're looking for that indicate that you have work to do in that scene? The word that always stops me in my tracks when I'm reading a script would be the word office Because offices are just absolutely full of paperwork. You know, like notice boards and filing cabinets and desks covered in all kinds of paperwork.
作为例子了，因为那根本不是我想表达的意思，你知道，确保道具正确本来就是他的工作，确保道具正确也是我们的工作，确保道具正确也是我们的工作。这就是我们在为电影布景制作东西时所经历的那种来回沟通，日常的来回沟通。所以在做剧本拆解时，你在寻找哪些关键词来表明你在那个场景中有工作要做呢？每当我读剧本时，总有一个词能让我停下脚步，那就是“办公室”。因为办公室里绝对塞满了各种纸质文件。你知道，比如公告栏、文件柜以及堆满各种纸质文件的办公桌。
So that's a huge set for the graphics department. There are lots of scenes that have a very low volume of graphics naturally. Like, you can kind of skim read a sex scene really. Nobody ever pulls out a newspaper or starts looking in a map. So funny. Let's talk a little bit about, so once you get the list of things that you have to work on, you begin to research what those things are, what they're like for this film. And could you describe what the research is like? So I start my research, I do a little bit of research online, but I find
所以这对平面部门来说是一个巨大的布景。有很多场景自然而然地只有少量的平面元素。比如，你基本上可以一目了然地略过床戏。从来没有人会突然掏出一份报纸或者开始看地图。太搞笑了。我们来聊聊，一旦你得到了需要处理的事情清单，你便开始研究这些东西是什么，以及它们在这部电影中应该是什么样的。你能描述一下研究过程是怎样的吗？所以我开始做研究，在网上做了一点研究，但我发现
that looking things up on the internet can be misleading for a couple of reasons. First of all, nobody really ever labels anything properly online. Like if you find, if you find a beautiful vintage map on Tumblr, there's absolutely no way it's going to tell you what year it's from or what the dimensions of it are. And then also, it's really difficult to judge by looking at pictures on a screen, the scale of things, and also the texture of things. So if I have to make a telegram, for example, I really need to go to a flea market and find an old telegram that I can hold in my hands,
在网上查阅资料可能会由于几个原因而产生误导。首先，网上的东西从来没有人真正好好归类过。比如如果你在Tumblr上找到一张精美的复古地图，绝对没有办法告诉你它是哪一年的或者它的尺寸是多少。其次，通过看屏幕上的图片，真的很难判断事物的比例以及质感。所以如果我必须制作一份电报，例如，我真的需要去跳蚤市场找到一份可以拿在手里的旧电报，
and then I know what kind of paper to make it out of, and I know exactly what the measurements of it are. So I do a lot of my research in flea markets, in junk shops, buying old pieces on eBay, markets in junk shops, buying old pieces on eBay, raiding my grandmother's attic, that kind of thing. What are some of the other tricks, so you do everything by hand when it would have been done by hand? What does it take to make a piece of paper look old? And you're making it brand new, and handing it to somebody.
然后我就知道该用什么纸来制作它，并且确切知道它的尺寸是多少。所以我很多研究都是在跳蚤市场、旧货店、在eBay上买旧物件，洗劫我祖母的阁楼之类的场所完成的。还有哪些其他的诀窍？本来该手工完成的东西你都亲自手工制作吗？怎样才能让一张纸看起来很旧？而你明明是在制作一张全新的纸并把它交给人。
How do you make it seem and feel real? The aging process for a prop is a little bit of a tricky balance. It's a tightrope because the pieces usually should have been brand new at the time, at the time that the show is set in. But when you're making a period drama, a lot of the time audiences need to see a little bit of aging to really believe that they're in the period. You know, it's like we need to see a little bit of aging to really believe that they're in the period. You know, it's like we need we need to see the cracks in the canvas of the oil painting because that's how we see it in the gallery. We need the paper to be off white or slightly yellowed because that's how we look at all documents now. But if you go too far in that
你是如何让它看起来和感觉起来真实的？道具的老化过程是一个有点微妙的平衡。这是一根走钢丝，因为这些物件在秀所设定的那个时代通常本应该是崭新的。但当你拍摄年代剧时，很多时候观众需要看到一点岁月的痕迹，才能真正相信他们身处那个年代。你知道，这就像我们需要看到油画画布上的裂纹，因为我们在美术馆里看到的就是那样。我们需要纸张是乳白色的或微微发黄的，因为现在我们看所有的文件都是这个样子的。但如果你在这条路上
direction, then all of a sudden everything looks a bit like, I don't know, like an old pirate map, right? Yeah. So it's a tricky balance, and it varies from show to show. Some directors and production designers want to go for a real kind of seepia look in everything, and then other directors want to really work with the colours that they would have used at the time, which is one of the reasons why it was so wonderful working for Wes Anderson, because he really embraced the colors of the period. And instead of doing that whole seepia-tone thing
走得太远，那么突然之间一切看起来都有点像，我不知道，就像一张旧海报地图，对吧？是的。所以这是一个微妙的平衡，每部剧的情况也各不相同。一些导演和美术指导希望一切都呈现出一种真正的乌墨色调，而另一些导演则希望真正运用那个时代本会使用的颜色，这也是为什么为韦斯·安德森工作如此美妙的原因之一，因为他真正拥抱了那个时代的色彩。而不是采用那种全套的乌墨色调，
that we do a lot of the time if we're working on some kind of old drama. Right. Is there another, I wanna get back to Grand Budapest Hotel and Wes Anderson in a second, but are there other examples of things that you researched and you know what is accurate for the time, for example, something being new when it was actually new, but you're balancing that against expectations of what people want or expectations of the story so that for some reason the accurate
如果我们参与某种老旧年代剧的话，我们经常会这样做。没错。有没有另一个，我一会儿想回到《布达佩斯大饭店》和韦斯·安德森，但还有没有其他的例子，关于你研究过并且知道符合时代的事实，比如某样东西在它实际是新的时候就是新的，但你要在这一点与人们的期望或故事的期望之间进行平衡，以至于由于某种原因，准确的
representation is not the proper representation for the thing that you need for it to do in that story. So we try to start every single prop that we make for a film with a real historical artifact that we can copy basically. And that means that we're making things that feel really authentic instead of like a movie prop. So one example would be newspaper design. Newspapers are used a lot in film because they're really good storytelling device. If you need to tell the audience that there's a war being fought, then you can show a newspaper headline saying there's a war
再现并不是为了让它在故事中发挥作用而应当采取的正确呈现方式。因此，我们尽量为电影制作的每一个道具，都从一个我们可以基本照抄的真实历史文物开始。这意味着我们制作出来的感觉非常真实，而不像电影道具。一个例子就是报纸设计。报纸在电影中经常被使用，因为它们是非常好的叙事工具。如果你需要告诉观众有一场战争正在打响，那么你可以展示一个写着正在发生战争的报纸头条，
on rather than shoot a 30 second battle sequence, which is going to cost however many million dollars. So we would start with the real reference of a newspaper, but actually a lot of the time in particularly in England in the beginning of the 20th century, the broadsheet papers didn't actually have newspaper headlines on the front pages at all. The front pages were covered in small ads advertising local businesses and things for sale. So what I do when I start a project is I'll talk to the director and the production designer about this. You know I'll bring them the information and tell them like this is actually what a newspaper front page was like. And then
而不是去拍摄一个要花好几百万美元的30秒战斗场面。所以我们会从报纸的真实参考资料开始，但实际上很多时候，特别是在20世纪初的英国，大报的头版头条其实根本没有新闻头条。头版上密密麻麻都是关于当地企业和待售物品的小广告。因此，当我开始一个项目时，我会与导演和美术指导谈论这件事。你知道我会把这些信息带给他们，告诉他们——这实际上才是报纸头版原本的样子。然后
they make the call whether they want to stick with historical accuracy or they just want to ignore that and design the newspaper to suit the story that they're telling. There's a line that gets bandied about in film art departments and it always goes something like we're not making a documentary about 19th century newspaper layout. We're telling a story. We're telling a story. Is there a part of you that really enjoys it when it's really accurate or do you get more pleasure from it just being really good and serving the story the best way possible or do you get the most excited when you can you know just kind of marry the two? It's exciting to study real references because what I find a lot of the time is that the truth
他们来决定是坚持历史真实性，还是忽略这一点，将报纸设计成契合他们正在讲述的故事的样式。在电影美术部门流传着这样一句话，通常类似于：我们不是在拍摄一部关于19世纪报纸排版的纪录片。我们是在讲故事。我们在讲故事。你心里有没有一部分真的很享受追求绝对真实，还是说你从它真的很棒并以最佳方式服务于故事中获得更多快乐，或者当你能够，你知道，将两者完美结合时，你会感到最兴奋？研究真实的参考资料令人兴奋，因为我发现很多时候真相
is more interesting. If I started a prop with just a blank page and illustrator, I wouldn't be able to create something as interesting as what has actually been designed before me. My imagination can't compare to the collective imagination of the hundreds and thousands of craft people that have gone before me over the last hundreds of years. So it's interesting to look at something real and then develop it with the director and the production designer to suit the story
比想象更有趣。如果我只从Illustrator里的一张空白页开始做一个道具，我是无法创作出像摆在我面前的那些历经岁月设计出来的东西那样有趣的内容的。我的想象力无法与过去几百年来无数工匠的集体想象力相提并论。所以，观察真实的事物，然后与导演和美术指导一起根据故事进行开发，是一件很有趣的事情，
because then you can make something that feels authentic but it's also interesting, visually. And so when I'm watching your work in movies, you've put a lot of time into them, but do you want me to notice them, or do you want me to kind of ignore them? I kind of feel that if the audience is looking at my pieces of graphic design, then the film isn't necessarily working, right? The attention of the audience should really be on the drama that's unfolding between the characters, like the drama between the humans.
因为这样你就能做出既有真实感又在视觉上很有趣的东西。所以，当我看着你在电影中的作品时，你为它们倾注了大量时间，但你是希望我注意到它们，还是希望我忽略它们呢？我个人觉得，如果观众在看我做的平面设计，那么这部电影可能就没有发挥好，对吧？观众的注意力应该真正集中在角色之间展开的戏剧冲突上，比如人与人之间的戏剧冲突。
I think you should notice it, but only subconsciously. Like, we are building a world, and we're using graphic design to do that. But the pieces are so fleeting, I don't think you should really register everything consciously. When I watched things that I worked on back with my mother, I'm always very keen that she notices everything. I'm always shouting at the TV, you know, I made that, I made that, I made that, and she's always like, what? What?
我认为你应该注意到它，但只能是潜意识层面的。比如，我们在构建一个世界，我们正在利用平面设计来做到这一点。但这些作品是如此稍纵即逝，我认为你不应该真的有意识地去捕捉每一处细节。当我与母亲一起重温我参与过的作品时，我总是非常渴望她能注意到一切。我总是对着电视大喊，你知道的，那个我做的，那个我做的，那个我做的，而她总是说：什么？什么？
I didn't even see anything. This is a conundrum of almost all design that the best stuff is meant to work and do its job, but kind of not be noticed. And is there a state of mind that you've gotten into where you can accept that, or is it just come naturally to you? I've never felt cheated in any way that my work doesn't get screen time. I only ever feel thrilled when it does get a little bit of screen time. There's something thrilling about having your work shown on a cinema screen. I don't know what it is. When
我什么都没看到。这是一几乎所有设计的悖论：最好的作品本就应该发挥作用并完成使命，但却不怎么引人注目。你是否进入过一种能够接受这一点的精神状态，还是说这自然而然地就流露出来了？我从来没有因为我的作品没有获得银幕时间而感到任何委屈。每当它确实获得了一点银幕时间时，我只会感到兴奋。把自己的作品展示在大银幕上是一件令人激动的事情。我不知道为什么。当
I worked in advertising years ago, you know, I would design billboards, but I never got really excited driving past a billboard that I designed. Whereas, if I'm sitting in the cinema and something gets like a fraction of a second of blurry screen time, then for some reason I'm really excited by it. blurry screen time then for some reason I'm really excited by it. I don't know what that is. I suppose it's like the whole Hollywood star system thing getting to me. That's I think that's fair. You can give yourself that enjoyment of being on a movie screen. Have you ever really labored over something that got cut from a scene and that that pains you at all. Yes, you work on things all the time that you put a huge amount of effort into that just never get seen at all on the on the screen or by the camera. I would actually say that most of
多年前我从事广告工作时，你知道，我会设计广告牌，但我开着车经过自己设计的广告牌时，从来没有真正兴奋过。然而，如果我坐在电影院里，哪怕某个东西只有零点几秒模糊的银幕时间，出于某种原因，我都会为此感到无比兴奋。模糊的银幕时间，出于某种原因，我都会为此感到无比兴奋。我不知道这是为什么。我想这就像好莱坞明星体系的那一套影响了我吧。我认为这很公平。你可以让自己享受那种出现在电影银幕上的乐趣。你有没有曾经为某个最终被从场景中剪掉的东西付出大量心血，而这让你感到一丝心痛？是的，你一直在为那些投入了巨大精力却根本没有在银幕上或被镜头捕捉到的东西工作。我甚至可以说，我的大部分
my work is like that, but there are people who see it and the people who see it are the actors and the director. And it's really exciting to build, say for example, a street scene and put up all these street posters and shopfront signs and hanging signs and pieces of period advertising. And to see the actors arrive on set in the morning and take in the surroundings and really you can see them feeling like they're being transported to another time. And then, you know, they go and they do their acting and I hope that maybe our work as film designers contributes a little bit to them really getting into their roles.
工作都是这样的，但有人能看到它们，看到它们的人是演员和导演。而且，比如说，搭建一个街景，挂上所有这些街头海报、店铺招牌、悬挂式招牌以及带有时代感的广告，看到演员们在早晨到达片场，吸收周围的环境，你真的能看到他们觉得自己被带到了另一个时代，这非常令人兴奋。然后，你知道，他们去演戏，我希望也许我们作为电影设计师的工作，能在某种程度上帮助他们真正融入角色。
Yeah. If you ever had an instance where an actor really fell in love with a proper something that you made. I remember when we were shooting Gran Budapest, there was a prison scene with Harvey Kytel and Ray Fines. And Ray Fines was admiring the prison escape map that Harvey Kytel's character Ludwig had drawn. And Gustav, the character played by Ray Fynes, admires its artistic promise. And I remember when I read that script page being
是的。你有没有遇到过某个演员真的爱上你制作的某个道具的情况？我记得我们在拍摄《布达佩斯大饭店》时，有一场哈维·凯特尔和拉尔夫·费因斯的监狱戏。拉尔夫·费因斯在赞叹哈维·凯特尔饰演的角色路德维希画的越狱地图。由拉尔夫·费因斯饰演的角色古斯塔夫，对它的艺术前途赞赏有加。我记得当我读到那一页剧本时，
really excited because it's very rare that characters in a script admire a piece of graphic design, you know. So I knew that this was going to be a big one for the graphics department. So we made this prison escape map and it was drawn on the back of a piece of packaging paper. So we also included like packaging label and postage stamps and franking marks and we really went all out on creating these pieces for this imaginary country, the Empire of Zubrovka, that was created. And when Harvey Kital arrived over from LA to do the scene, he suggested that he and all the people in the, all the other actors in the scene actually go and stay in the prison. It was a real prison that we were shooting
真的非常兴奋，因为在剧本中，角色赞叹一件平面设计作品的情况非常罕见，你知道的。所以我知道这对平面部门来说会是一个大工程。于是我们制作了这张越狱地图，它是画在一块包装纸的背面。所以我们还加入了包装标签、邮票和邮戳，为了创造这个虚构的国家——祖布罗夫卡帝国，我们在制作这些物件时可谓全力以赴。当哈维·凯特尔从洛杉矶赶来拍这场戏时，他建议他和片中的所有人，片中的所有其他演员，实际上都去监狱里住一晚。我们是在一个真正的监狱里拍摄的，
in, go and stay overnight in the prison and take these props with them so that they could get into character. So that was really fun. The thought of them all going off to this remote prison in the east of Germany, in the middle of February, in the snow, and taking the props that we'd made to help and get into character. If you were to pick up a script tomorrow, what would you read in the script that would make you really excited to make that thing. I like designing things that you have to design as a character in the film rather than as a graphic designer. For example, a prison escape map. It's not really a graphic designer's job, traditionally, to design that, right?
去监狱里过夜，并把这些道具随身带着，以便他们能进入角色。所以那真的很有趣。想象他们所有人都在二月中的雪地里，前往德国东部那个偏远的监狱，并带着我们制作的道具来帮助自己进入角色。如果你明天拿起一个剧本，你在剧本中读到什么会让你真的感到兴奋去制作那个东西？我喜欢设计那些需要你作为一个电影里的角色去设计、而不是作为一个平面设计师去设计的东西。例如，一张越狱地图。传统上设计这个并不是平面设计师的工作，对吧？
It's a prisoner's job to draw that themselves, so you really have to get into character and try to figure out how that character would have drawn something like that and what tools they would have used to do it. You know, what would they have had access to pens or charcoal or crayons or and what kind of paper would they have had access to and what would their style be like? Well, so you mentioned that, you know, for the most part, your work isn't noticed in that spy design, but with the world of, you know, streaming video and the internet where people can pause and discuss the graphic design of things, you know, people do notice and probably notice mistakes. Yeah.
这是一个囚犯自己画地图的工作，所以你必须真正进入角色，并试着弄清楚那个角色会如何画出这样的东西，以及他会使用什么工具来完成它。你知道，他们会接触到什么，是钢笔、木炭还是蜡笔？他们会接触到什么类型的纸张？他们的风格会是怎样的？所以你提到过，你知道，在大多数情况下，你的作品在谍战设计中并没有被注意到，但在流媒体视频和互联网的世界里，人们可以暂停并讨论事物的平面设计，你知道的，人们确实注意到了，而且可能注意到了错误。是的。
The IMDB Goofs page is absolutely full of continuity errors and a lot of them are about graphic pieces. So one example is, when jobling is at the gas station, the calendar on the wall says October 1932, but shows October 5th, 12th, 19th and 26th as Sundays. In 1932, those dates fell on Wednesdays. When we made the calendar, we didn't think to check the days against the dates for 1932 those dates fell on Wednesdays. LAUGHTER When we made the calendar we didn't think to check the days against the dates for 1932, but then we didn't think anybody else would either. LAUGHTER
IMDB的穿帮页面上绝对挤满了连贯性错误，其中许多都与平面道具有关。例如，当乔布林在加油站时，墙上的calendar（日历）显示的是1932年10月，但显示10月5日、12日、19日和26日是星期日。而在1932年，这些日期其实是星期三。当我们制作这个日历时，我们没有想到要去核对1932年的日子与日期。这些日期落在星期三。笑声 当我们制作这个日历时，我们没有想到要去核对日子与1932年的日期，但我们也没想到其他人会去核对。笑声
I can read that kind of thing and think, you know, there's such pedants, but they're right. And when I look back at the pieces that we made, I see that yes, there is an error there. The next job I went on to, who would have been Spielberg's Bridge of Spies, which was a true story, we made a lot of newspapers for that film. And I remember beginning to check the dates against the days because I wanted to get it right.
我看到这类事情时会想，你知道，这些人真是死板，但他们是对的。当我回头看我们制作的物件时，我发现，是的，那里确实有一个错误。我接下来的工作是斯皮尔伯格的《间谍之桥》，那是一个真实的故事，我们为那部电影制作了大量的报纸。我记得开始根据日期核对星期，因为我想把它做好。
And then eventually the prop master said to me, do you know what, I think we're just going to leave the dates off because it wasn't clear the sequence that these things were going to be shown in. And he said, you know, if you leave the date awful together, nobody will look for it. But if you put something there that's wrong, then it might jump out. We went with no dates in the end for those newspapers. So when you were doing the design for the Grand Pit West Hotel, there was an error that caused them to have to redo a bunch of the work. And it was on these little pink cake boxes and from the fictional bakery called Mendels. Can you tell us that story?
后来道具主管对我说：“你知道吗，我觉得我们还是把日期去掉吧，因为这些事情呈现的先后顺序并不明确。”他说：“你知道，如果你把日期完全去掉，没有人会去找它。但如果你放了错误的东西在那里，它可能就会跳出来。”最后那些报纸我们都没有标注日期。所以当你为《布达佩斯大饭店》做设计时，曾出现过一个错误，导致他们不得不重做大量的工作。那是在那些写着虚构面包店名字“门德尔”（Mendels）的小粉红蛋糕盒上。你能给我们讲讲这个故事吗？
Yeah. How far through the shoot, Wes got in touch and said, I think there's a spelling mistake in the Mendels box. And I said, I don't think so because I take such great pride in my spelling and grammar. And he said, there's two teas in participy. And I looked at the box and I realized that he was right. And of course, I had hand-letted that text so it had never gone through a spell check. And you know, it's a word of French origin.
可以。在拍摄进行到一定阶段时，韦斯联系我说，我觉得门德尔的盒子上有一个拼写错误。我说，我不这么认为，因为我对自己的拼写和语法一向非常自豪。他说，participy这个词里有两个t。我看了看盒子，意识到他是对的。当然，那些文字是我手写上去的，所以它从来没有经过拼写检查。你知道的，这是一个源自法语的词，
I really should have double checked it. I should have triple checked it, and I just didn't. And at that point, we had shot so many Mendelssox boxes, which shot, I think, 2,000 of them. And it had to be fixed in post-production, which is great. It's great that we have the option to fix things in post, but it's a kind of a lengthy process because you have to change
我真的应该仔细核对的。我本该三番五次地核对，但我就是没这样做。而那时候，我们已经拍了无数个门德尔的盒子了，我想我们拍了大约2,000个。这些必须在后期制作中修复，这很好。很高兴我们有在后期修复问题的选项，但这是一个相当漫长的过程，因为你必须改变
whatever it is, 25 frames per second. So it can be quite expensive as well. So that was embarrassing. Since the film was released, the Mendelssohn's box has kind of taken on a life of its own. It's kind of become a bit of an icon for the film. So people are selling them online and people are making their own fake boxes and selling them and trying to pass them off as real props from the movie. But I know when I look at them that if there's two teas in participy, then it was really in the movie. If you ever see a box of two teas in participy, you should buy it.
每秒25帧的画面，无论那是什么。所以这可能也相当昂贵。所以那真的很尴尬。自从电影上映以来，门德尔的盒子已经有了它自己的生命。它在某种程度上成了这部电影的一个标志。所以人们在网上售卖它们，人们还在制作自己的假盒子并出售，试图将其当成电影中的真道具蒙混过关。但我知道，当我看着它们时，如果participy里有两个t，那它就是电影里真正的道具。如果你看到一个写着两个t的participy的盒子，你应该买下它。
And these were really iconic looking. They're in piles and they're these pink cubes. They're really a very active part of the scenes that they're in, too. Yeah. They're what we call a hero prop. A hero prop is any prop that gets a bit of screen time or has a kind of character of its own. You can generally tell what a hero prop is because it will have a description in the script.
这些看起来确实极具标志性。它们堆成一堆，是一个个粉红色的立方体。它们在它们出现的场景中也确实是非常活跃的一部分。是的。它们就是我们所说的“英雄道具”。英雄道具是指任何获得一定银幕时间或具有某种自身特性的道具。你通常可以通过剧本中的描述来识别什么是英雄道具，因为它会在剧本中有一段描述。
Like a lot of things that we make aren't even mentioned in the script. Like if there's an office scene, then it's just assumed that we will know what to dress into that office. You know, the script won't go into details about notice boards and filing cabinets. But a hero prop will always be at least named and mentioned
就像我们制作的很多东西在剧本中甚至都没有被提及。比如如果有办公室场景，那么大家就默认我们会知道如何去布置那个办公室。你知道，剧本不会去详细描写公告栏和文件柜。但英雄道具至少会被点名和提及，
and sometimes described as well. When we come back, we'll hear from Annie about one of the most difficult props to design, money. So to follow up on this conversation next week, we're doing a whole episode on the design of fake money for the movies and the challenges that prop designers face creating a currency that has to look real but not so real that they get busted for counterfeiting. So to preview that story, I asked any accounts about her experiences designing money. So most of the time when I have to create a currency for a movie, I'm really recreating it because most movies are set in the real world. So I'll find vintage banknotes and I'll scan them and clean
有时也会被描述。当我们回来时，我们将听安妮讲述最难设计的道具之一：钱。为了跟进下周的对话，我们将做一个整集节目，专门探讨电影中假钱的设计，以及道具设计师在创造一种必须看起来真实、但又不能真实到因伪造而被抓的货币时所面临的挑战。为了预览那个故事，我问了安妮·阿金斯关于她设计货币的经验。所以大多数时候，当我要为电影创造一种货币时，我实际上是在重新复刻它，因为大多数电影都设定在真实世界中。所以我找到复古纸币，把它们扫描并清理
them up and reproduce them. There are problems with that. I think Photoshop, you know, doesn't let you do this. It tells you it's illegal, but you can get around it with a little hack. And then for things like Granboro Pesto Tell, I was creating a fictitious currency because it was a fictitious empire. So that was good in the sense that I didn't need to worry about legal clearance, but it was really tricky because designing a bank note is actually really difficult. I'm sure it takes people months and years to design bank notes and you know, we had whatever it was, a fortnight. But are there legal considerations when you're designing bank notes?
干净，然后复制它们。这样做是有问题的。我认为Photoshop，你知道的，不允许你这样做。它会告诉你这是非法的，但你可以用一个小技巧绕过它。然后对于像《布达佩斯大饭店》这样的东西，我创造了一种虚构的货币，因为它是一个虚构的帝国。所以从不需要担心法律审批的角度来看，这挺好的，但它真的很棘手，因为设计一张钞票其实非常困难。我确信人们要花几个月甚至几年的时间来设计钞票，而你知道，我们只有无论多少时间，反正就两周。但在设计钞票时有什么法律考量吗？
Well, yes, you need to get it past legal clearance. So things have to be changed slightly. I mean, I haven't actually made any modern money because I've never done a contemporary movie. But I have designed things, for example, for the CIA and the FBI for true stories. So we've wanted to use the real logos, of course, because we want everything to feel authentic,
嗯，是的，你需要通过法律审批。所以有些东西必须做出微小的改变。我的意思是，我实际上没有制作过任何现代货币，因为我从未拍过当代电影。但我确实设计过东西，例如，为真实故事中的中央情报局（CIA）和联邦调查局（FBI）设计过。所以我们当然想使用真实的标志，因为我们希望一切都感觉真实，
but that doesn't get past legal clearance. So you have to do things like flip the eagle on the departments of state logo. You know, in the American seal, it's an eagle holding things in his claws. Yeah, like arrow is in stuff. Yeah, you have to change what the eagle is holding in which way his head is facing, that kind of thing.
但那通不过法律审批。所以你必须做一些事情，比如把州务卿徽标上的鹰翻转过来。你知道，在美国国徽上，那是一只爪子里抓着东西的鹰。对，就像箭之类的东西。是的，你必须改变老鹰抓着的是什么、它的头朝向哪个方向，诸如此类的事情。
And I guess the same would work with currency as well. If you wanna hear a lot more about the dangers of designing prop money, what you have to do is listen to next week's 99.000. 99% invisible was produced this week by Emmett Fitzgerald in Avery Trouffleman, music by Sean Riel. Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colstead is the digital director.
我想货币也是一样的道理。如果你想了解更多关于设计道具货币的危险性，你必须收听下周的“99%隐形”。本周的“99%隐形”由埃梅特·菲茨杰拉德（Emmett Fitzgerald）和艾弗里·特鲁夫曼（Avery Truffleman）制作，音乐由肖恩·里尔（Sean Riel）创作。凯蒂·明格尔（Katie Mingle）是我们的资深制作人，库尔特·科尔斯特ッド（Kurt Colstead）是数字总监。
Rounding out the team is to review Sif, Delaney Hall, Terran Masa, and me, Roman Mars. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row in beautiful downtown Oakland, California. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRX, an independent collective of the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. We are supported by the night foundation and listeners, who are donors, who pitch in whatever they can to keep us doing what we're doing. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook.
完善这个团队的还有特里维·西夫（Tove Danovich/Tove Sif）、德兰尼·霍尔（Delaney Hall）、泰伦·马萨（Terran Massa），以及我，罗曼·马尔斯。我们是旧金山 91.7 KALW 的一个项目，制作于美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心电台街（Radio Row）。“99%隐形”是 PRX 旗下 Radiotopia 的成员，这是一个由播客界最具创新性的节目组成的独立集体。请在 radiotopia.fm 查找所有这些节目。我们得到了奈特基金会（Knight Foundation）以及捐赠者听众的支持，他们慷慨解囊，助力我们坚持做我们正在做的事。你可以在 Facebook 上找到本节目并加入关于节目的讨论。
You can tweet at me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org, where I'm on Instagram, Tumblr, and Reddit too. But if you're thinking, I need more 99PI in my life, we have all the old episodes and new articles about design that current rights every couple of days. On our beautiful, beautiful website, it is at 99pi.org. Radio tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你可以在 Twitter 上@我 @Roman Mars，或@节目 @99PI org，我在 Instagram、Tumblr 和 Reddit 上也叫这个。但如果你在想，我的生活中需要更多的 99PI，我们拥有所有的往期节目，以及常驻作家每隔几天就会更新的关于设计的新文章。在我们美丽得不行的网站上，网址是 99pi.org。Radiotopia，来自 PRX。本期节目暂无评论。点击转录文本中的任意句子即可留下评论。